before I forget who do I  um  how many humans do I have to kill I mean  dragons to have to kill to get myself  somehow into uh Elder Scrolls six so mod  if anyone wants to create mods of me  and is that is that possible yeah as  possible  uh while maintaining realism somehow  if you don't want you don't want a  person in a suit and tie  it doesn't make you put you in both put  you in Fallout you can wear that yeah  please put me so follows there's also a  culture of uh you do a mod where you  replace the mysterious stranger  there you go that's the to-do task empty  top mod right there and you will have my  deep gratitude and more dear stranger  for doing so  um what's the programming language for  mods is it mostly their use our internal  scripting language that's built into the  tool  okay I'm almost afraid to explore that  world because you will never never turn  back